WOULD HAVE REMAINED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: BESIDES CHRISTINE
FORD AND KAVANAUGH HIMSELF,
THE CHIEF FIGURE IN THE
HEARING TODAY WAS THE ARIZONA
PROSECUTOR RACHEL MITCHELL.
DID SHE ASK THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS OR MISS ANYTHING
IMPORTANT?
POSSIBLY RHETORICAL QUESTION.
WE HAVE THE NATIONAL
COORDINATOR FOR NATIONAL
CHILDHOOD INTRADICTION AND SHE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
I WATCHED THE HEARINGS AND I
KEPT THINKING HOW ALONE BRETT
KAVANAUGH WAS.
I AM NOT ATTACKING THE
PROSECUTOR WHO ASKED IN THE
FIRST HALF BUT KAVANAUGH SEEMS
TO BE THE ONLY ONE MAKING A
CASE FOR KAVANAUGH.
>> YOU KNOW, TUCKER,
UNFORTUNATELY I AGREE WITH
YOU.
ALTHOUGH THE WAY I LOOK AT IT
IS THAT KAVANAUGH WAS THE ONLY
PERSON EVERYONE TRYING TO
CHALLENGE THE ALLEGATIONS,
WHICH I THINK IS THE ROLE OF
MISS MITCHELL.
SHE DID A COUPLE THINGS WELL,
ESTABLISHING POSSIBLE
POLITICAL BIAS IN THE SENSE OF
THE DELAY OF THE HEARING.
THIS RIDICULOUS ALLEGATION
THAT SHE WAS AFRAID TO FLY.
SHE CERTAINLY BLEW THAT OUT OF
THE WATER.
AND THE ELUCIDATION OF THE
ISSUE OF WHETHER OR NOT
DR. FORD DELAYED IN HER OWN
WORD COMING FORWARD WITH THE
INFORMATION.
SHE SAID THAT SHE KNEW ABOUT
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S POSITION ON
THE SHORT LIST AND THAT SHE
WAS DETERMINED TO PREVENT HIS
NOMINATION.
YET, SOMEHOW THIS Ph.D. WAS
UNABLE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CALL EITHER OF HER TWO
SENATORS.
BOTH OF WHOM SIT ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MISS MITCHELL DID A GOOD JOB
WITH THAT BUT WHEN IT CAME TO
ASKING ABOUT THE ALLEGATIONS I
WAS SHOCKED WHEN SHE TOLD
DR. FORD SHE WOULD NOT BE
ASKING HER ABOUT THE
ALLEGATIONS AT ALL.
AND SHE DIDN'T.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
LIKE BUYING A NEW CAR AND NOT
MENTIONING A PRICE.
ON THE PLANE THING, SHE
ESTABLISHED THAT CHRSTINE
BLASEY FORD HAS FLOWN AN AWFUL
LOT.
SHE COULD HAVE TEASED OUT IS
WHY SHE LIED ABOUT IT IN THIS
CASE.
WE CAN'T COME TO WASHINGTON TO
TESTIFY BECAUSE SHE CAN'T GET
ON AN AIRPLANE.
THIS HAD A POLITICALLY
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT.
DELAYING THE CONFIRMATION OF
KAVANAUGH.
THAT IS LIE.
WHY IS NOBODY SAYING THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I THOUGHT JUDGE KAVANAUGH DID
A BRILLIANT JOB EXPLAINING
WHAT THE DELAY MEANT TO HIM,
HIS FAMILY AND HIS REPUTATION
AND THEIR FUTURE.
PROSECUTORS LIKE TO SAY DON'T
ASK A QUESTION YOU DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER TO.
SO DON'T ASK A WHY QUESTION?
ALL TRAINED PROSECUTORS KNOW
THAT IS GARBAGE.
YOU HAVE TO ASK QUESTIONS YOU
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO.
IN EVERY TRIAL YOU OFTEN DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER.
SHE SHOULD HAVE CHALLENGED
DR. FORD AND SHE DID NOT.
>> Tucker: I NOTICED.